زينه الشوارع الاجتماعات العائليه لقاء
الاصدقاء والمسافرون العائدون للاحتفال مع
اسرهم ساعات قليله تفصلنا عن اول وجبه
سحور في شهر رمضان ما بين وجبه الافطار
الاولى في الشهر الفضيل واخر وجبه عطاء
غير محدود وجعل ولعل ابرز ما يميز الشهر
صناديق وجبات الافطار حيث تختلف الاماكن
في العالم الاسلامي وسباق الخير واحد نذكر
في صباح العربيه بتقليل هدر الطعام قدر
المستطاع المشكله التي تزداد عاما بعد اخر
وتتركز بشكل اكبر في عالمنا العربي حيث
ترمى الاف الاطنان من الطعام في النفايات
واليوم نتحدث عن توجهات الاستهلاك في
رمضان اين السحور والافطار مع الشيف محمود
فرنجيه الذي سيكون معنا
والمزيد عن سلوك المستهلك في رمضان 2023
مع الزميله لميس
تحولات تشهدها اتجاهات الاستهلاك في رمضان
هذا العام في السوق الاماراتي من المتوقع
ان يزداد التسوق عبر الانترنت والمزيد من
المدفوعات الرقميه بحسب موقع عادت زيارات
متاجر البقاله عبر الانترنت ارتفع في
سبتمبر 2022 بنسبه 28% مقارنه سبتمبر 2019
وهذا مؤشر مهم على سلوك المستهلك المتوقع
في رمضان من عام 2023
خلال رمضان 2022 حققت مشتريات تطبيقات
التسوق في رمضان نموا بنسبه 64% ومن
المتوقع ان يحافظ رمضان 2023 على نفس
النمو مع تحول المزيد من المستهلكين نحو
الطلب عبر الانترنت في الامارات ايضا
وبحسب شركه اتش ال بي يتناول 46% الافطار
خارج المنزل مره واحده على الاقل اسبوعيا
وسته وعشرون بالمئه يستخدمون خدمات
التوصيل خاصه في النصف الثاني من رمضان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فقره المفضله هاي الاكل وفي الاستوديو
ينضم الينا استشاري في مجال المطاعم
والصناعه المحتوى الشيف محمود فرنجيه صباح
الخير صباح النور لك لجميع المشاهدين
كثير اسئله بس اهم سؤال بدنا نبدا فيه
يعني ما هي الابتكارات فيما يقدم الشيف
محمود من اطباق لرمضان هذا العام هلا
رمضان الجديد دائما صراحه دائما عم نروح
نحن على الاسهل لانه بيتغير يعني اليوم
نحن نفس الاكل التقليدي بس اليوم كيف بدنا
نلاقي طرق جديده نسهلوا على صبايا مثلا
الجداد المتزوجين او ستات البيوت او حتى
الجيل اللي بيشتغل انه هلا صار نسبه يعني
الاناث بيشتغلوا كتير مو مثل الاول فاليوم
مثلا بتعطي بس مكونات خفيفه ولا طريقه
الطهي
مثلا كوسا بلبن مثلا
الذكاء الاصطناعي يحفرها عنا
بدل ما نحفرها اليوم نقطعها ممكن نستخدم
مثلا لحمه كيوبس اوكي يطلع بالنهايه نفس
الطعم بس احنا مكعبات كانوا احنا جزئناها
يعني لانه اليوم انت تغير الاكل بحد ذاته
مو كتير لانه صراحه بحس انه في غلط اليوم
اذا غيرنا الاكل التقليدي لانه تقريبا عم
نطلع من هويتنا لانه الاكل هو هويه وثقافه
بالنهايه هو مو بس انه الشعب ناكله فممكن
نحدث اليوم طرق جديده انه نسهل عمليه
الطبخ
مهمه جدا وحتى في احصاءات تقول انه اليوم
الاطعمه الفروزن مثلا بازيلا فروزن
المقطعه البروكلي المقطع الخضروات المقطعه
اليوم صار عليها اقبال اكثر لنزول المراه
الى العمل اكثر اريد اسالك هل الطعم يبقى
نفس الشيء اذا استعملت فريش او فروزن هلا
الطعم ممكن يكون كتير قريب بس صراحه اكيد
القيم الغذائيه بتختلف هلا انا مع الفروزن
اذا نحن ساويناه بالبيت صراحه يعني ممكن
نخصص وقت معين نساوي شغلاتنا اللي بدنا
اياها اكيد بعرف احنا مشغولين كثير بس
اكيد بفضل لانه دائما شغل المعمل او شغل
المطعم
اكيد في اختلاف اكيد يعني حتى بقول انا
يوم بالامارات هو اللعبه لعبه مواد مو
لعبه شيف عم يطلخ طيب او عم يلعب لعبه
مكان مشان المواد كتير محمود شفنا كتير من
الطواف العالم
بقوموا
بتهجين اذا صح التعبير الطعام نخلط مثلا
السوشي الياباني مع
السيفي تشيل
البيروفي انتو شوف شو عملتوا اليوم كشفت
كشاف محمود بالاكل العربي كيف هجمته
هالاطباق هل انا كشخصيا شوف الاطباق طبعا
العربيه هي بس بدها طريقه تقديم معينه ما
بحب كتير ندخل بتغييره يعني انا هيك انا
بشوف شو رايك انه المذاقات لا تخلط يعني
انا بالنسبه الي مثلا الحمص في الافوكادو
هو محمص ممكن نسميه ديب افوكادو يعني لانه
فعليا يعني الوصفات العربيه مختلفه كتير
على الاوروبيه لحد الان المطبخ العربي
ماله مصنف يعني او حتى مكتوب بالطريقه نفس
الطريقه الاوروبيه يعني انا عندي البشاميل
اليوم مثلا 90 غرام طحين 90 جرام مثلا
زبده لتر حليب مما سواها بتطلع تقريبا نفس
الشيء بس طبخه عربيه اليوم لما بنعمل مثلا
اول
مسخن فلسطيني مثلا
المقادير لانه انا بامن بالاكل العربي في
نفس قبل العلم الاكل الاوروبي فيه علم
بعدين بيجي النفس هذا الاختلاط اريد استغل
الفرصه بما انه انا خلفيتي اقتصاديه فاريد
اسالك بدايه انت قبل شويه تكلمنا تحت
الهواء انه يعني شغلك الاساسي هو تقديم
استشارات لفتح مطاعم يمكن كل شخص
مرحله من مراحل حياه تفكر انه يفتح مطعم
فشو هي النصائح اللي تعطيها للاشخاص اللي
يفكرون يفتحون مطعم اليوم يعني اهم
نصيحتين خلينا نقول الاهم نصيحتين لازم
نعرف ليش بدنا نفتح مطعم
ممكن نفسي ولا مادي لانه انا المطعم
بس في ناس كتير معنوي ممكن هو برستيج
المطعم لشخص ويكون
اقتصاد ما لي علاقه
الثانيه لازم يكون عامل ميزانيه كافيه اقل
شيء لسته اشهر يعني عنده ميزانيه
انه هو خسران او 6 اشهر ليقدر يكمل نكون
بالارباح يدخل ولازم يفتح اذا بده يفتح شي
مثلا بالامارات لازم نفتح شيء كبير لانه
الشغلات الكبيره بتنجح الشغلات الصغيره
متوسطه يعني الفرصا تكون ضعيفه وهذا يعتمد
على ثقافه البلد بالضبط
على اساسه لينجح لو فتح شي كتير بسيط
بصراحه مختلف عن بلادنا فما حيكون ناجح
ميه محمود فرنجيه الاستشاري في مجال
المطاعم شكرا جزيلا
بعد رمضان ان شاء الله رمضان وانت بخير
تسلم